because he had honey to send this video
you guys won't watch this one no we're
not not on the podcast this one okay I
mean it's it's like heartfelt and the
guy put bagpipe music to it and he put
like and and they were I did a cameo for
this guy who was a you're still in cameo
yeah I do it all the time but it's what
I already went yeah sure but I make a
lot of money on it okay no but I it so
so if I have something I want to give
money to it's yeah or pay you or pay my
bills um for the eyelid surgery
I'll never do it but listen yeah I'll
never pay for that that way but um this
guy made this video yeah and you'll
watch it later and I was watching it and
I was like any put back pie plate now
please redeem yourself no just watch it
no because we know we everyone hate you
right now this can be so much better I
did this you're a retired the shortest
man in the military the shortest man to
ever serve in the military don't laugh
I'm not laughing
and he was a green beret in Vietnam he's
four foot by four foot nine four-lane
greenery and he died this is he died he
became homeless
he served in one like all these medals
and he said Vietnam in Vietnam any many
and he passed away five years ago
but he died homeless he was homeless and
so this cop this awesome police officer
who I think was also a green beret I
said I want you to do this I want you to
do a cameo for this guy kind of say some
words for him here's and I researched
him I looked him up and I went and he'd
wanted me to kind of do a eulogy for my
guests did they play it at his funeral I
don't I think they did I think they
planned I didn't realize I I didn't know
this dude put it to music
and to a collage and you know you forget
I was doing it I I did feel some in a
while ago about about a week ago I was a
little bit but I felt when I read about
this guy was really inspired and I just
kind of spoke from my heart and
off-the-cuff and this dude made this
video and I found it so moving even
though it was my own words it's not why
I was doing it but when you put bagpipes
you have his back fives on anything
right it's good oh so watch listen it
was caught
clarity who was hot topic stop you can't
see what happens
hey it doesn't
I saw bread and do this and we add the
weight this is the Bobby Lee situation
we gotta wait no I'm good I swear to god
I'm good rest in peace go back you know
what's weird is the other soldiers will
the tallest I know why they do that so
why are he was he was the shortest man
I've ever shot in the military it's
actually an insane what's insane is not
there is four seven they know that if
they use a green beret
oh it's nuts and they say go swim across
through the tunnels yeah Bryan condos
the Vietcong that's the Vietcong wife is
he's small long had a system of tunnels
I know
alright so they would send him in well
of course you would well you're not
going in I can't blame the devil he's
going in he's a nice bug in the bath
dude he's the best at it I know the best
yes but it is play action it is pretty
awesome and pretty moving and a bunch of
green brace chip to him being brave
money be going good they bought him a
headstone they bought him a headstone ha
ha
and they gave him a proper burial they
don't know it's a very sad story sir
said yeah we want it so you can see it
alright the whole thing here who was the
smallest
was a green beret in Vietnam what a
brave dude you know I guess he was 4 9
97 pounds smart 97 pounds got a Silver
Star two Bronze Stars two Purple Hearts
well may ninth fifth year he's been God
he was homeless I think about these
things we're all lucky that we don't
fall through the cracks
all of us can't I don't give a [ __ ] who
you are Malka how good you are I don't
care how hard you worked
I don't care about any of that stuff
there go us by the grace of God that's
what I say maybe you start taking credit
for your success for your health for
anything you better be careful heart
beat in a heartbeat you know so I I read
stories like this and it fills me with
compassion and it reminds me of never a
judge and it reminds me to stay humble
and it reminds me not to think of myself
in any way it's better than anybody else
and that's you know better has no
children no no no someone like her gonna
reminds me of that I just just stuff
that I read pictures I saw dude I can't
believe it this is better in the Rudy
know this guy know Rudy was offside make
a movie about he's played this dive
fought for your freedom but to them to
the bagpipes sounds like I've written
it's like I'm doing it sounds like it's
a movie like I'm marylee movie what
sounds I just thought well I am I am I
was just doing in the Vietnam War I said
I'm glad I wasn't no where were you
during the draft not born yet you were
born in the 70s do you mind I was born
in 1967 I was a little baby okay like
you know I'm sorry any blank you for
stopping draft dodger ah never seen chin
laughs all right I'm so sorry when I get
the gills I can't stock you know neither
the problems we're not supposed to laugh
yeah yeah is it so he tell me not to and
then you don't then you're like yeah
he's small and then they show the video
and he's forced that well it wasn't
ready for because it's astonishing
it's amazing what he was a baby and he
was he was Rudy get a movie I know and
this guy does it I know
and then just died homeless you know
anyway I'm watching this as this guy's
putting bagpipes to it and it sounds
like I
this morning by itself is like super I
got emotional yeah in here night my own
words in here not so much with the three
of us but in here not so much because
we're you're all dead behind the eyes
and you're not American there's oh
there's a I was so humble it looks like
a child
yeah that's with all these soldiers it
was a green product in one picture they
have him at the deli at the counter with
that with that cop it sound nuts and
then and then he what a stud yeah look
at that and they just became alright on
their holy Wow look at this that's come
on come on is that crazy or weird out
much harder is for him when they're
running in and let me tell his jungle
Vietnam and the Green Berets went
through some [ __ ] in Vietnam well - I
mean in the Vietcong jeez yeah I mean it
wasn't they were our Special Forces they
were you know I mean I it's just uh
Richard a flatter flatter celerity
Flaherty and Irish clarity yeah captain
captain and then just became the the the
homeless things above it yeah and
forgotten and forgotten until this one I
wish I could know I'm I wish I could
give a shout-out to the police officer
because I think he was a green beret or
something like that and Eddie sent that
to me Eddie sent it to me Yeah right
and how about there it is that's crazy
yeah I think you're right I never
thought there should be a movie about
that the smallest guy in the military
I'd watch a Steven Spielberg would make
that movie a four foot who would play
the character Steven private dirty yeah
who would play that who would play that
find an actor who's that small you'd
have to find a legit oh that's English
Oh a different kind of the English isn't
athletic enough to be a green beret you
need a small man you basically need
somebody who's totally proportioned
okay you do you need so yeah you can't
have a small person cuz they're not
gonna have them well that's that's a
dwarf there's a dwarf is what cereal
gives your your boy didn't have dwarfism
here's the small person right he's a
small person so dwarfism is different
that comes with horf where the dwarfs
can't be or small people can't be in the
special it's very
I don't think they can run their talents
there's many things in too many shoes
yeah but and also their asses fit in the
pants all that stuff dude but that guy
you've got to be is that is that it's an
article on military.com Diller a 4-foot
inches dude do they have a picture if
I'm the Giant Killer it's just that's
him right there and then uh Dan that's
not we can play this I'm telling you
they're gonna make a movie about this I
don't know if that was really makes it
but he certainly didn't show any plows
he shot all those people down what had
happened when the river [ __ ]
and I think it was in what we called the
a quick bill at that time it's long a
thousand-meter
village that rent with a river running
through it and it was a gnome area where
you're gonna get contact you've never
went Annie a quick bill without running
into the end for some reason they just
kept coming back there and so we're
doing a sweep and my unit had jumped
some North Vietnamese and Vietcong on
one side of the river and we shot
several of them but they did not they
weren't dead and I was gonna call for
medevac helicopter you know a desktop so
you get him out of there so because I
had the medics work on him you know
looked like okay well there abouts
tables they're gonna get and so I'm
radio over the Richard and I said I've
got to Victor Charlie WIA and he said
Roger to Victor Charlie ki a and it said
no no WIA
so when to be on whiskey India alpha and
he says no he kept coming back with the
ki a and I knew what he was saying
because he was saying basically what
let's just move on
kill them let's just go Wow and I had
guys in my platoon they're looking at me
going yeah we don't want to do this I'll
tell you that's it so Miami police
officer David music befriended a
homeless man after 15 years of
friendship Richard J Flaherty finally
revealed who he was music learns that
this unassuming 69 year old man was a
decorated military veteran so that
that's shout-out to Miami police officer
David
so hilarity is killed by a hit-and-run
driver and he was hit by a hit yeah
killed by a hit-and-run driver he did
time in prison for drugs yeah I'm sure
you know yeah all right enter than
fiction tales that would never make it
as a movie peach movie pitch because
it's so unbelievable
so what kind of a movie hits called the
Giant Killer I'm sorry they kind of did
like a documentary movie called the
Giant Killer like it's on iTunes in okay
Amazon huh
well there you go okay the Giant Killer
then also him doing time in prison for
drugs they don't know if it's just a
cover because he did some undercover
work of his a real compel a lot time
fooled there a lot time fault really
really interesting man that's crazy
four foot nine crazy yeah oh I got the
Giant Killer yeah man
dan was hit by a car that sucks your
story's crazy it's definitely a movie
worthy story I think it is a movie where
the story yeah I hope they optioned it
maybe I'm gonna send that to uh joe
carnahan and frank grillo that's the
kind of movie they write oh yeah who's
the actor who's the shortest actor in
Hollywood there's this there's a small
as out right like who's the the guy that
played John Lent no John you know could
play it Breckin Meyer Britton Meyer is
that my buddy and I romantic reckons
five four it's still too tall it's a
little too tall but you could get tall
actors around whole soldiers and widths
with CGI now you can do all kinds of
weird [ __ ] I guarantee there's a guy
who's four four four seven or four nine
where the [ __ ] you us who ya do it
they're out there this guy Taran
Edgerton that played Elton John I think
about Elton John how long for short I
think he's pretty short I don't think
he's that short though let's see five
nine no right now never mind
this short it's an actor I can think of
is that guy from Hannah Montana Moises
arias he's like 5-1 moist oh well you
know sure does that
Jon Snow okay oh yeah judge snows
oh he's 5-3 he's [ __ ] 5-3 or z55
that's it next time though he's now
that's him next to Edgerton and he was
five six yeah it looks like he's
probably around five six oh and your boy
has heels on there too so yeah let me
see a five five
boy he's a tiny fella John snow sprite
five five dams too big dikembe mutombo
compared to four stuff yeah that's a
short guy Johnson oh that's my my hate
it nice shorter than five eight we'll
find someone we're out there yeah yeah
Brendon shop let's plays the giant Danny
DeVito for Tao yeah Danny DeVito would
be Little Joe Pesci five four hold on go
back thank you Nunez would be great oh
yeah Thank You Venus he'd be great at it
Bruno Mars uh he's not that short that's
really short Kevin Hart Scorsese is five
for Scott Caan's only five five yeah
he's timing Scott Caan so short Scorsese
short Jason Alexander Bruno Mars that
cliff would be great um I'll go back for
a sec damn Dreyfuss is only five five
Lucy if woody I wanna do it yes cots for
says God's a super macho guy like he's
it yeah you know he's a white rapper
Scott copies got it yeah is it used in a
straight legit rap group
well hey Theo sure that's James Caan
yeah again white rapper there's guys on
five nine I've worked with him Elijah
Wood Elijah Wood is tiny yeah all the
hobbits are Ralph they're small in
general Eugene's make a boy go back the
voice who Jon Stewart it's awesome call
it Culkin Miller Susan was calling
Culkin was so small five seven Ben
Stiller five seven Tom Cruise five seven
actors got the smaller actors are Al
Pacino is even smaller than that Joanie
help us on David's burger front is only
five eight yeah I thought he was
actually smaller for some reason yeah
these are Hollywood so you got to got
about two inches Mark Wahlberg is go
back
yeah he's short five eight I don't even
know if Mark Wahlberg five eight yeah
well you gotta remember these guys have
shoes are adding some inches yeah oh it
should keep look I wrote anything only
five nine what yeah yeah I thought Brad
Pitt was old taught in five eleven
but he's my height I've never seen him
in person mmm-hmm all right yeah good
luck with this right now
yeah yeah yeah yeah watch your tongue oh
what's gonna happen what are you gonna
do use some of that boxing you've been
doing
[Laughter]